hello everyone as I'm making this video
who even has a promising position
against Wayne Jones and it starts to say
if she will be able to convert it into a
whole point but it seems that around 9
might be might be her around but let's
get back to our real game this is uh Nev
Geary with the black pieces against
Russian Grandmaster Maxime matter code
and it seems Geary is little by little
becoming the star of the show here in
this game we have an epic moment in
chess history Geary offered the draw not
by actually offering the draw here for
the tree for a three-fold repetition and
Maxine metrical declined it so this is
something we don't see very often Geary
offers a draw and his opponent the
clients so let's see let's see this
interesting moment
Metallica has the white pieces and he
opens with Knight to f3 the reti opening
we have d5 g3 and Bishop to g4 the
terrace variation of the Kings Indian
attack and this is something I often
like to employ against players who go
Knight to f3 because I just want to
exchange that light square bishop to get
rid of it that light square bishop
always annoys me whenever I play I would
like but then sometimes my opponent
strongly would Knight to e5 and then i
have to play something I have no idea
what I'm doing
but getting back to this game Bishop to
g2 by matlock of c6 we have castles and
Knight to d7 h3 Bishop to h5 and D for
now ecigs c4 and Bishop to e7 Knight to
c3 D captures on c4 and we have b3
offering that full pawn Geary of course
accepts this C capture some b3 Queen
captures on b3 and immediately Queen to
b6 offering a trade of Queens as you're
a football up so Queen to a4 declining
the trade of Queens Knight G to f6 rook
to be 1 attacking the Queen Queen to c7
Bishop to a4 now developing a piece with
a temple on the Queen and c7
we have Queen to c8 and rook F 2 c1 and
what did Matlock really gain for his
pawn he has very nicely developed rooks
both Knights are active this Bishop is
on a very nice
long diagonal here this bishop here and
g2 isn't doing that much now but if the
position on the Queen side opens up he
will have quite a lot of compensation
for the material but if you look at the
position there's really nothing to go
for immediately so the position is squat
all right for black it's you know
passively comfortable or comfortably
passive or however you prefer it but
it's just the way Geary likes it
so Gary castles we have Queen to b3 now
I mean that b7 point and here we have
Bishop to g6 attacking the rook and b1
rook has to move and now we have rook to
dat the reason Gary doesn't defend the
pawn is that there's no need to defend
the pawn immediately but let's just say
why it would be a bad idea to defend the
pawn even if it's a better idea if you
play something like this then after a
night to h4 the bishop and g2 comes
alive and then this bishop and this
bishop are simply monsters
so after this rook to be to get replace
the correct move rook to d8 and here we
have a four we have a five and the
reason why it's not okay to grab the
pawn if you capture them Bishop to a3
this simply grabs material Wednesday
exchange so after up to d8 we have a
four and now a five-night to d2 we have
90 to h5 attacking in the dark square
Bishop to Bishop to e3 and Knight H back
to f6 and this is the critical moment in
the game here if you look at the
position this here move Gary played
night to h5 we have Bishop to e3 and
Gary moves the knight back Knight to f6
and if I'm at local repeated the
position here Bishop to f4
it's you know there's really no no good
moves here for blacks and it's hard to
say if Geary would repeat night to h5
but it's very hard to find a better move
than night to h5 so basically here by
returning Knight f6
theory offers a draw and Matlock hope
does not go for Bishop to f4 going four
threefold repetition but instead plays
Knight to c4 with the idea that now the
Knight is guarding the a3 squared
there's no more
with Bishop to a three so now Matlock Oh
is ready to capture mb7
Gary plays Knight to d5 we have Queen
captures and now comes Bishop to b4 now
cutting off the rooks defense of the
Queen and b7 so the Queen's get
exchanged Queen captures rook captures
uncie eight and nine - eight - attacking
the bishop and before
Knight captures on e3 we have F captures
on e3 and c5 now either threatening to
break open the center or add any more
defense to the bishop on before we have
Knight to d6 going after the rook and
here we have Bishop to a3 Knight
captures row conciliate Bishop capture
some b2 and now Knight to e7 check
wherever the king goes the knight will
capture the bishop on g6
which checks Oh King f8 better to
improve the position of her King Knight
captures H captures and rook to c2
Bishop goes to a3 and if you look at
this position that the matlock of really
improve his position when he decided not
to go for Bishop to a4 or is this
position now actually favoring black
well it's definitely not favoring white
I think here we have a classic case of
pushing for something when you actually
have nothing just because you have the
white pieces against someone like Geary
and that's that's definitely never a
good idea so Bishop to c6 we have C
capture son d4e captures on d4 and now
rook to c8 so if I mean okay they are
opposite colored bishops but there are
still knights and rooks on the board so
it doesn't really look like a draw or
anything and if you look at this White
has three point islands black has two
point islands so again a favorable
position for for black we have III here
King to e7 improving the position of the
King King to F one Bishop to d6 and g4
now nice to be six
rook the c1 we have Bishop 283 wrote
back to c3 and Bishop to b4 and here
I think Matlock off just didn't want to
play that rook to c2 because he's
this rook started his journey from c-2
and he didn't want to admit that
actually rook to c1 to c3 was a mistake
so instead of going rook to c2 he
decided to capture the bishop but better
was rook to c2 and allow Geary to go
Knight to d5 this does threaten to
capture an e3 for king the king and the
rook but after king to e2 he can still
continue this game but after this Bishop
to b4 he decided to capture it Knight
captures and pawn captures and while
this does create a passed pawn for white
it actually creates a much more
dangerous pass pawn for black so rope to
c5 and the rook can't really go on idea
any other file other than the C file as
it does have to protect the bishop here
and the bishop can't really move from c6
as it has the block this rooks attack
towards this rook so not not a
comfortable position for for a white
rook to c5 was played but now comes b3
as there is no piece that can stop the
journey of this pawn a5 white tries to
push but now comes Knight Knight d7
attacking the rook and here it's all
over black Matlock off simply resigned
the game as there was nothing he can do
to prevent the journey of this pawn he
would have to move the rook and then
simply lose the piece
rope will have to move and then after
rook captures he's just a piece down and
it's it's an unplayable position
so after this knight move Matlock will
resign the game and a great victory for
onigiri who just basically played a nice
passively comfortable or a comfortably
passive game with the black pieces
offered the draw and after his opponent
refused just made most out of the
position in hand so this is something
that happened to me quite a lot quite a
lot of times and I'm sure it happened to
a lot of you you know you play and it
doesn't matter even if you're playing
against the stronger opponent you have
the white pieces you maybe feel you're
feeling the pressure we have to win so
you go for it and then you lose the game
so bye-bye this game Geary is now in
Seoul first place and
it's it's a bit early to tell anything
but you know it's a it's a very nice
position to win the tournament he
already faced Magnus he drew that game
and there are four more runs to go so
anything can happen but you know
definitely after nine rounds being in
first place definitely an achievement so
like I said I don't know maybe he fans
the game against going Jones already
finished - maybe she managed to score
her first victory if so I will
definitely show that game across on an
and drew their game very early so no not
much action there and I think most of
the games were drawn so not not very
exciting round in the touch steel chess
tournament you know it's always after a
rest day they will either you know bring
fireworks or it will be just a calm calm
day so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with a first win from - see
you soon